I have been such a fan of yours for
years like years and years I'm like oh
my God I'm so excited I remember when
you were on tour with Beyonce really
what was that like it was really
exciting and all those people out there
and I was like we get to perform in
front of the people who came here to see
Beyonce
Beyonce like knows what time it is she
knows who she wants to share space with
and I think that you and your sister are
you know you take the World by storm
people are
um you know very fascinated by you guys
but like I mean is is it true like when
you even saw
um How These Little Mermaid trailer
what was your reaction I was screaming
and I was crying and I was in my t-shirt
and underwear about to get my makeup and
hair done for the Oscars After parties
and I dropped everything and I was just
screaming because
she is a real life mermaid a siren
graceful in all her beauty and people
get to see what I've always seen since
we were little girls and what she's
going to do for all the young kids
around the world to see her to know that
they can be anything that they want to
be it doesn't matter what Society tells
them I know that's going to be so
inspiring and it even inspires me and I
am the proudest big sister in the entire
world oh my God that's the most I really
am I really am
she's amazing she's amazing what I love
about you guys too is I never wanted to
be just one thing you know you sing You
Dance you do drama you're funny like
what's your favorite man okay so my top
number one number one number one love
will always be music okay because I'm
such like a nerd and like the whole
production and Engineering side is
really exciting for me and then with
acting I recently really truly fallen in
love with it within the past two years
because I released this idea of needing
to be perfect on screen and that's when
I really fell in love with the art
because I was just allowing it to take
me for the ride on its own what did you
have to tell yourself because we can all
fall prey to Our Own Worst insecurities
demons like yeah I wonder sometimes if
anyone could say anything worse than I
say to myself I'm working on that me too
I'm working on it too let's keep in
touch and please tell like encourage
each other you know because there is so
much love flowing it's ironic we would
put any stock Gap in there with our own
but you know everyone has their stuff so
how do you overcome it how I overcome it
so I'll cry it out first I'm gonna be
honest I like that I pray I call my God
Mom and I'll call Hallie and my siblings
and I'll just cry and cry and they'll be
like boss up and I'm gonna be honest
when my album came out last week
congratulations thank you it I never
thought the day would come so when it
actually happened I was like trying to
figure out every way in my head to like
make sure it wasn't happening or like it
was like imposter syndrome so I keep
reciting to myself I deserve it I
deserve it I deserve it I deserve it and
I think we owe it to ourselves we have
to give ourselves flowers before we
expect anybody else to and that's what
I'm learning it's hard but I'm learning
[Applause]
I love that I also really loved what you
said about you call people that you
trust and that can help
just wow well I have to talk about your
film praise this I'm obsessed like it is
so you like it I love it it is so fun
and
you know
this film is so positive it just it's so
delicious and yummy and it's fun and
it's cool and it's got music and it's
got a good message and I just I think
this is what we turn to you know when we
need to fill our own cups or buckets and
we just want to escape it's like all of
that is in this film and I just really
really love it I'm so happy you do that
means everything coming from you yeah
it's like it's just got all of them yeah
it looks the best time filming it like
we were laughing non-stop the entire
entire entire time but it's like at the
root of it it's a good message that
reminds you you can come as you are and
you'll be accepted and loved because
you're you and that's what I really love
about the film um okay is it true
um that you hate a certain food
yeah will you play a game with me that
might interest towards failure or
success in maybe having to eat they hate
food I love games so I will say it
because that and I love you yes okay
good I'm scared and I'm excited we're
gonna play a game
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign